until the end of october 2021 there's
the first ever theories of everything
merch at the link in the description or
you can visit tinyurl.com
tow merch t-o-e-m-e-r-c-h
les strout is a canadian survival expert
and a filmmaker best known as the
creator the director the producer the
writer the cameraman and the host of the
television series survivorman which has
now been uploaded to youtube via the
survivorman channel and the links are in
the description at les's heart he's an
artist and thus we touch on what
originality is what art is and isn't at
least subjectively and the positive and
a pugnant underbelly of what it feels
like to have one's work mimicked we also
touch on bigfoot experiencing orbs and
how les's attitude has influenced my
approach on not only the ufo topic but
topics that are despised in general
click on the timestamp if you'd like to
skip this intro for those new to this
channel my name is kurt jaymungal i'm a
filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of what are called theories
of everything from a theoretical physics
perspective but also delineating the
possible connection consciousness has to
the fundamental laws of nature provided
these laws exist at all and are knowable
to us if you enjoy witnessing and
engaging in real-time conversation with
others on the topics of psychology
physics and consciousness then do check
the description for the theories of
everything discord and subreddit there's
also a link to the patreon that is
patreon.com kurt jaimungle if you'd like
to support this channel as the patrons
and the sponsors are the only reason i'm
able to do this full time it would be
near impossible to have conversations on
the topics of consciousness and loop
quantum gravity and so on with such
depth if not for the sponsors and the
patrons so thank you that link again is
patreon.com with regard to sponsors
there are two the first sponsor is algo
algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce return and
inventory write downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by a
bright individual by the name of amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception
additionally amdad has a podcast on
artificial intelligence and
consciousness so if you'd like to
support this channel that is theories of
everything then do visit his channel
which is in the description and
subscribe to him as doing so helps this
the second sponsor is brilliant
brilliant illuminates the soul of
mathematics science and engineering
through bite-sized interactive learning
experiences now brilliance courses
explore the laws that shape our world
elevating math and science from
something to be feared to a delightful
experience of guided discovery you can
even learn group theory which is what's
being referenced when you hear that the
standard model is based upon or has
local symmetries of u1 su-2 and su-3
visit brilliant.org
toe that is t-o-e for 20 off the annual
subscription and i would recommend that
you don't stop before four lessons give
it at least four lessons and i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can comprehend subjects you
previously had a difficult time rocking
thank you and enjoy this digressive
conversation with les stroud do you mind
giving the audience an overview of your
survivorman series and then how it led
up to the bigfoot series
yeah years old i mean if you think about
it survivorman started
uh so here's the here's the overview i
guess that survivorman started for me in
the year 2000 even 1999 because that's
when i pitched it and 2000 is when i did
the first um
pilot version for it and then 2001 i did
the second pilot in 2000
uh
two or three is when i launched it into
a full series called survivorman so it
predated all of the sort i mean
basically it it was the zeitgeist for um
the genre known as survival tv and i
know that sounds like a horrible boast
to make myself but historic history
would bear me out on that um without
survivor man you don't get
naked and afraid you don't get a loan
you don't get mad versus well you don't
get any of these other shows without
survivor man having sort of been there
first
and i can also say that you know
uh case in point is that uh nobody
wanted survived men when i first tried
to pitch it or not nobody uh it took a
while before i found somebody who gave
me the opportunity in fact i was told on
one occasion
no one this is from a nic this is a
quote from a network executive
no one will ever want to watch people
surviving on television
that was a quote right so and i said no
i think you're wrong and of course now
look what we have you know um and so
really survivorman
then you know continued on um
all through the 2000s
uh for a good 18 years really now along
the way when the uh you said what led up
to redman bigfoot so to fast forward to
that situation
is that eventually at some point i got
you know a bit tired of it i was looking
for um variety in my work i love variety
i love i don't want to do the same thing
all the time and at the same time also
they the shows that
came out started copying what i was
doing of course they couldn't actually
do it let's be clear about that they
were not actually surviving none of them
were um
with the exception of now
alone but alone is also very produced
in the edit suite so you're not getting
the story that actually happened so no
one even to this date has ever done what
i did with survivorman and that was
actually survive on actually film but
the problem with that is i couldn't
deliver a lot of episodes too hard on me
so then they came along and they wanted
they wanted to have more and more
episodes more more episodes so they just
basically started up with bear grylls
and all the rest of them
well
seeing that i wanted you know i said
look i want to go off into some other
directions i did i did beyond survival
which was my series uh going out and and
surviving with indigenous cultures and
taking part in all kinds of ceremonies
so that was still to date my
the best work i think i've ever done
and then the bigfoot thing happened
because
normally i try to work creatively on
things that come out of my own brain so
it's not all not already out there in
other words i'm i'm inventing something
but every once in a while i do adopt the
richard branson version which is
basically build a better mousetrap when
i saw what finding bigfoot did i just
thought no they blew it they completely
screwed that entirely and it could be so
much more potent than what they did so i
created survivement bigfoot there it's
hard to ask me a quick a question about
something that happened over 20 years
and helped me answer it in one sentence
that's for sure totally fine okay and so
what was survivorman bigfoot edition
so survivement bigfoot edition was
basically
me
producing what ended up being a 10 part
now an 11 part i did an additional one
uh documentary series
uh exploring the phenomenon
called sasquatch called bigfoot
and so i would go out and place myself
in in these
various situations not not not as in a
sensational way not not in a campy way
not even in and certainly not in a
scripted way but you know your uncle
would say no i've seen one i've seen
them a couple of times they do come
through my valley in my backyard and i'd
say okay do you mind if i camp in the
valley in your backyard
and then let's see what can i i want to
see what's possible here and that's it
was going in as a skeptic
uh with eyes wide open and a very
open-minded skeptic
and then filming what i thought were
solid and strong documentaries
on the phenomena that's all it was
really
yeah i've unconsciously modeled myself
after you and i have well the channel
has a great deal to owe to you because
much like yourself where you didn't go
in with too much credulity nor dismissal
you were playing the middle ground i too
have done that when it comes to the ufo
topic
where i'm not believing whatever is told
to me but i'm also not dismissing it
just because it's it sounds outlandish
and i think a part of your appeal is
that you're not a cryptozoologist
a similar like i'm not a ufologist and
so people actually like that that
someone from the outside is going in and
investigating this
well uh
oh yeah absolutely i think that that's
been my my
my
i don't know certainly not a schtick and
certainly not a gimmick but it's my
thing and always has been all the way
along look i didn't come out of a
privileged background um other than my
maybe my skin color i didn't come out of
a privilege background my background was
very low income there were gangs in the
neighborhood lots of drugs a
dysfunctional family
so um i came you know i came from an
alcoholic background um i've had my own
issues you know when i was younger so i
have all that in my background what does
that mean
it means that
i'm not
that
guru guy for survival i'm not that
tv celebrity for my face on camera
i'm just a person who used to load boxes
on the crates in warehouses as a job you
know i came from many blue collar jobs
and that's that all of that kind of
background
and it means am i relatable i suppose
you were you would say i'm relatable but
why why am i relatable because i'm just
like you i'm i'm not i'm not you know
but here's the difference
the difference
and the chasm that i place between
myself and say my past is that i seek to
find
a life
that is filled with
edifying components that that i'm
trying to expand my brain i'm trying to
correct to connect
the scenario that's the synapses
synapses in my brain i'm trying to make
new connections i'm trying to be smarter
i'm trying to learn you know when
someone corrects me on my grammar i'm
one of the few people that will not get
mad about that i'm like oh my god i'm
saying that wrong thank you for telling
me you know um
you know and i seek to learn from
larger minds so if i approach a subject
matter that is seemingly in the genre of
like that's oh that's for like i said
rednecks down in alabama who likes
sasquatch well no i'm going to say no
let's let's give them some credibility
here let's
sure
you know it it seems you know what that
like
it should be relegated to people with
nothing more to do with their time than
sit around and read conspiracy series or
talk about bigfoot but it but if you can
elevate certain things to a place of
respectability where you can actually
research them you know that's that's
been my goal and so
look i i've
i've hung out let's say
and lived and grew up with enough of
the other part of society that i am the
other part of society
but i also seek to be the
the very successful side as well uh what
do you mean whether my filmmaking well i
mean
well this is a this is a not a
conversation we're planning on getting
into but i will say that i just knew
there was always going to be something
better for me yes i did yes i did say to
myself at 20 years of age i know i'm
better than this
and that was didn't mean i'm better than
them or better than you i just knew i
was better than
this this
shitty alcohol strewn cigarette smoking
life i'm living i'm better than this and
i just always knew it and so i've always
uh sought to to achieve something it
took me till i was 45 you know so case
in point when did survivorman the first
episode come out i mean how old were you
when it first came out so the pilot then
here's the great way that you ask that
because the pilot was when i was around
um
40 years of age wow and i was 42 i think
when i landed the series i was
now on air for four more years so now
i'm 46 right i've been on air with
television on television with
survivorman for four years i'm now an
international
tv celebrity i'm doing interviews i'm on
jimmy fallon and ellen
and i'm still
making
at the age of 45
46 000
per year
that's my take-home revenue when i was
45 years old i'd already been a tv
celebrity i'm already there i made it
with survival yet i was still only
making about forty six thousand dollars
a year
the next year is went up for the first
time in my life i broke the poverty line
so i'm now i'm a man of 46 years of age
i have two children at home and a wife
that doesn't work and at 46 years of age
because of survivor when it was the
first time i ever broke the poverty line
all of that goes back to saying that you
see that's where i come from so i'm not
a highfalutin you know
i'm not i was not a dancing monkey like
mr grills wanted to be i was not a tv
star like almost so many reality people
want to be yeah just a guy from a
neighborhood
with an inquisitive mind and hopefully
some
some
quotient of talent i don't know if
that's true or not but
and i just never left my let myself stop
you mentioned this monkey aspect and
when i think about celebrities like i
was watching
the met gala and i was saying billy
eilish if that's how you pronounce her
name and a few of the other celebrities
and then the paparazzi were saying turn
here turn here billy turn here and then
she turns and over here over here and it
just made me think oh my gosh do you not
feel like a monkey i wonder how much
they feel like they're just being pulled
and prod like a puppet
and
you mentioned that you don't
you don't want to be like that did you
ever feel like you were being pulled in
that direction
oh i was i was very often
they attempted very often to pull me in
that direction
and uh you know i was very much a fish
out of water when i was down in los
angeles let's say dude doing jimmy
fallon and then the next day going on
some other interview radio thing and
maybe you know the next week on ellen or
something like that
that that i always thought that
paparazzi hollywood celebrity lifestyle
to me
i'm just a guy from canada man and and
it was just i always felt so outside
watching it thinking oh my god and you
look in the vacant
eyes of the paparazzi or the person
asking you the interview sometimes you
get beautiful people interviewing you
but a lot of times they're they're on a
treadmill of what they think they're
supposed to ask you and
and so these philly maybe not her but
but these different people who they you
stop and you pose i walked the runway a
few times i the walk the red carpet and
i remember being told hey turn over here
last turn and
i
did it i think twice just to get through
the it's like well it was the only way
in and i had to go along that carpet i
mean one time i literally stuck behind
everybody and just kept going
unfortunately i wasn't big enough a big
enough star that nobody cared you know
if i brought them you know brad pitt
they would have stopped of course
so
it's
when you achieve a certain level
you know i've always said jokingly but
not that i'm just a c c celebrity i
think for a brief moment in time i
achieved b level status maybe b minus
status as a celebrity for a brief moment
in time and as i got closer as i saw
that i just thought this is not me i i
just i'm not this you know i'm a creator
i i
i believe myself to be an artist a
mediocre one i will say self-effacingly
yes but i still have always believed
that somewhere inside me as an artist
and that's what i try to be not there's
a big difference between being an artist
and a celebrity uh-huh uh-huh okay when
i'm looking at some of your new series
you have this lester out wild harvest
and and you have a podcast series and
you have i think another series coming
up or out
so what's driving this i assume it's not
money you said that your creative person
is a pure creativity
there's more than that this
yes is the short answer
because i desire to be creative but not
only that i desire
to be
a prolific
creative person a prolific creator i've
always admired artists like david bowie
frank zappa you know uh
anybody i mean back in the day people
used to do uh albums
four out two three four albums a year
then you know so i just love i just love
an artist who is prolific that's number
one that's driving me number two is is
is the is my my need to feel relevant
and when i say relevant let's be careful
about that how about my need
to
produce works
that matter
which i'm sure
sits on the shoulders of me
hoping to matter myself as a deeper
level but producing works is what i do
and i
so if i i just cannot produce
fluff that's not to say i haven't
produced shitty work i probably have but
i try not to and
i
i just can't
i'll give you a quick story i was on the
telephone with the producer one time and
we were brainstorming ideas and i said
oh i've got this one idea and i and i
said ah but you know i mean
i mean we could knock it out of the park
in in just like three months and it'd be
i know we would make a lot of money with
this but
ah that's kind of why i don't want to do
it i want to work on this other stuff
over here this morning and she started
laughing she goes oh my god les that is
so like you you just told me you've got
a project that you could do quickly and
it would be worth a ton of money and
that's why you don't want to do it and
she's laughing at me but it's like yes
that's why i don't want to do it i want
the challenge you know i like to do
stuff that
inspires other people
not just entertains
you mentioned that personally you may
feel this sense of mattering or this
lack of sense of mattering to the world
and partly what you do is driven by that
i'm curious if when you visit the
wilderness do you think there's that
drive because when you're in the city
you're one among a million or millions
and then when you're in the wilderness
there's this calm there's a sense that
you matter just as much as anyone else
is that
a motivator there
no actually it's not a motivator at all
i'll tell you why and the answer might
surprise you
firstly in the city
there is much more
pressure
to matter
around people there's much more pressure
to matter i think
uh or in my opinion i'd come across as
being quite selfish in my existence but
when i get out into nature when i'm in
the wilderness
i i i
i don't matter in the most wonderful way
i've never been asked that question
before and that seems like a funny way
to answer it
out in nature
i just don't matter anymore and it's
absolutely wonderful
and so that's why wilderness and nature
will always be my escape
you know
that's my my safe place
do you ever get into altered states
while you're in the wild not because
you've ingested something but because of
the experience itself let's say it's
meditative
well or perhaps maybe because of
injustice but um we can talk about that
later
yes i have
yes i have altered states as deep
uh as when i invoke the use of say plant
medicine or something like that no not
not as deep
but i blame my own personality for that
i'm a stub i can have a bit of a
stubborn
uh angle to me and so i've never truly
really gone into
great altered states through meditation
i know that it's incredibly valuable and
many people can i've tried for many
years i'm sure a teacher's out there
going i could show you how to get into
altered state i get it i totally get it
um
no i think my altered state in nature is
more of a gentle one where i just
feel at peace so see to me rather than
practicing a technique of meditating
well in nature i'm just allowing myself
to be
in nature and that is the meditation
what is it you said that there's some
stubbornness that prevents you from
using meditation to get to an altered
state what do you mean by that
i don't know um maybe it's like you
started asking questions about filming
bigfoot and i said you know i like to go
in as a very open-minded skeptic um
my my i mean through any seeking i've
done spiritually in my life
uh the
prayer side of that and the meditative
side of that
has never been one that truly
affected me
the people who have that affect them all
the time say oh you're just not fully
giving over yourself no that's not it
you know it's like that's
great it affects to you great but i've
tried very hard
and
it's just not and that's why eventually
later on in life when i went down the
road of working with plant medicines
that broke through in a massive way in
definitely a life-changing way so
so
meditation and i
we're not a perfect fit and now let's be
careful on this see the thing is
people can listen to motivational
speakers or spiritual this
a lot of times what those speakers
forget yeah
is that we all have these much different
personalities and a speaker often speaks
to you like
you should have their personality right
all the type a's the tim ferrisses and
the tony robbins of this world speak to
you like
here's what i do and every morning i get
up and i have my journal and this is
what you've got to do you really want to
be a success just let's go can i can you
know can i get an amen right cold shower
i'm like you know
well i do do the cold showers but that's
here i'm i i like the feeling i i
recognize that for example i'm a
multitasker
i cannot
be of a singular mind i cannot be
singularly focused and i'm 60 years old
this year i bloody well know my own
personality don't tell me that that's my
best way to go because you know what i'm
better when i multitask and when every
time i say that in a room you should see
the people go
thank god he said that oh thank people
thank me for because they feel pressure
okay
yes because they feel pressure from the
other motors i'm not from the unit
yes and that's not me never will be me
yeah you mentioned cold showers wim hof
have you followed him at all do you find
any of his practices i did my breathing
this morning um however i gotta i'd love
to ask him about this and i i saw it in
an faq but i was doing wim hof method
very successfully really enjoying it and
then one morning while doing it late
just like that i got hit with tinnitus
and i've had it ever since then i ch
then i i checked his faqs and people
been asking about tinnitus after the wim
hof method and it says don't worry about
it it goes away guess what it hasn't
gone away okay now 60 years of age i
just for the first time in my life have
tinnitus so if anybody's into him off
yes it's brilliant yes the cold showers
are brilliant anna his meditation
teaching is probably great though i
haven't gone down that road
but the the breathing it in me
do i know it caused it well let me say
that it
it happened
bam right in the middle of doing the
breathing
so as far as i'm concerned
i stirred something there and yeah yeah
i don't want to diss the wim hof method
believe me if you haven't heard if
people listening haven't heard of it
it's brilliant and i i like the cold
shower thing it really does zip me up i
but that happened to me anyway i'm i'm
venting a little on that because it's
unfortunate because i really enjoy the
breathing whenever i do the wim hof
exercise if i'm doing it properly around
that second or third time that i hold my
breath
then i get some tinnitus but it goes
away after about a minute my mine didn't
go away did you ever have temporary
tinnitus or you just had only permanent
tinnitus it just kicked in and never
left kicked in once and never left oh
boy
and i've never had it in my life
so you know i might i finally funny you
asked because i actually did the method
very brief i just did a short version of
the method this morning first time in
about three months because my ears have
calmed down
you know and
that's back oh boy i'm sorry about that
okay
when it comes to filmmaking you know
people who aren't filmmakers don't
realize how
let's say when i watch a movie i notice
plenty of what they don't do than what
they do
so what i mean by that is that they
chose not to show a shot reverse shot
that they chose to have it at two shots
at a two shot and to me i'm like okay
that's an interesting choice most people
notice
the presence of something not the
absence of something and in yours i
remember you talking about you didn't
want to include so-and-so element in
survivorman's what's some of what you
could have chosen to include that you
chose to exclude
and why
well first of all all of the cliches of
television filmmaking so all of the
cliches that other producers rely on as
a crutch
to
make up for the content they didn't get
so uh i i so so the
coming up next moment and the here's
what you missed before the commercial
moments all of that is a device it's a
device that just basically says oh you
don't have enough content to fill an
extra 60 seconds so you're going to do
15 seconds before and after every
commercial to fill up that time in your
show that's what i really think is being
said there i think it's achieved um
certainly um
within the filming of survivor man
there's two levels here right there's
the filming
and then there's the editing
two different worlds and in both cases
survivor man
enabled
or or rather
demanded of me
that i do things that no one else had
ever done because of necessity
the necessity was there's nobody else
there i'm alone
and so
i was doing things with the camera
that if you watch in history i can i can
as a brag say
i was the first person to do that
there's about six things that i was the
first person to do i did them out of
necessity because nobody was else was
there with me other shows picked up for
stylistic look as if they are alone but
really there's a whole freaking crew
there so can you give me an example to
do that well for example um uh
uh walking across a field
i'll set up a camera
at the halfway point i'll walk across
the field now my editor would pick up on
that because again in the edit suite
he's working now with footage that is
not shot like any other show so now he
has to do new editing techniques and
here you would see so i would come in
and i know you can see me so i would
come into frame and then it would be
like i would disappear but i would show
up in the middle frame then disappear
and show up at the end frame well i had
to do that because i did not have a
camera person following me and panning
me
everybody else can just follow and pan
they're out there with a big crew but
they set it up and they do it anyway
like give you that illusion that oh he's
alone you know no he's not alone at all
he's got a crew of six people with him
right whereas mine was necessity or how
about the selfie if i patented the
selfie man today i mean
when i did the selfie in survivorman no
one we didn't even have iphones when i
started that and and so there i was
holding a camera on myself that had
never been seen before ever until
survivorman and now it's ubiquitous
right so i could go on i mean that's
that was one of the beauties and the
things i loved about the filmmaking side
of this was i
was tasked with inventing methods that
would work for a person who's alone for
seven days filming himself
lots of things i had to develop my
editor
likewise had to come up with ways of
editing footage shot that way
and you sit back and look at our show
and everything else that was on tv in
2004
and we're doing all kinds of stuff
nobody else is doing
and then by 2008 everybody else is doing
it
and they're not alone that's the funny
part does a part of you feel resentful
about that or do you feel flattered
uh uh
that no no there's what i feel resentful
about is is having my my
my um format ripped off by the networks
absolutely i was very like screw them
they they written me off i should i was
asked if i wanted to sue them when i was
they were still airing my other works
was like it's like suing your mom like
it's like oh don't worry about it let it
go and no one's ever won a format
lawsuit by the way so no i'm not going
to sue them so i resent i'm resentful
about that but
the other stuff that we're just talking
about oh gosh no that makes me prouder
than punch to look at something and go
and not arrogantly just you know just
like
i know where that came from yeah you
love your mark just
to see that exactly i'll tell you i'll
tell you a quick story there was one a
very proud moment for me i was uh
talking with um a discovery producer
who's actually was the head of purdue
productions for discovery and we're over
the talking goes you know les goes and i
haven't seen him a long time ago i got
to tell you something he goes your
series beyond survival
is in my opinion the best documentary
series that discover channels ever aired
and he said
i use that series to teach my field
shooters how to film and my editors how
to edit
and then he started quoting
the classical editors and filmmakers
that my editor was influenced by like oh
he studied you know hossenfeimer from
the from the seven from the from the 40s
and like stuff like that and he was
right actually because my editor is
barry farrell brilliant man was very
schooled you know so our craft that came
out of necessity myself in the field and
barry in the editing suite that craft
has been um the people who know
no you know they they get they go okay
you know and again sounds like a brag
coming out of me but hell it happened
and history bears me out and i'm i'm
proud of them punched when i see stuff
if it's if it's man versus wild which
was a direct ripoff no that stuff is
just like you idiots you had a crew you
didn't have to do any of that stuff it
dorks you're just trying to look like
survivor man you know that's that was
but we're going back 15 years to get
that feeling
it's still there because you asked me
about it but by the same token that's
like 15 years ago when i was pissed off
at them i mean i'm not pissed off at all
anymore what's that ratio the ratio of
filmed footage to what actually airs
and i'm sure it's changed over the years
has it changed first of all well it has
loosely but if if it's done right um it
really follows the classic example years
ago
national geographic was the bar they
were the ones who put out the bar on the
standard on lots of different things
including ethics and filming it was very
interesting and you used to always say
well what does that geo say about it oh
they say this that that's gone that's
blown out out of the water they their
filmmakers have no accountability for
ethics whatsoever anymore they don't
give a crap they're just doing reality
tv and that's includes nancy oh wow and
all the rest of them but years ago they
were the standard right and the standard
years ago was four documentary films
forty to one forty hours to a one hour
documentary and i gotta say it
i pretty much helped with that sometimes
i was sixty to one sometimes maybe
thirty five to one but i always hovered
around that forty to one and and and you
know the filmmakers if they're you know
filmmakers listening to this right now
especially younger filmmakers when i say
younger i mean in your 30s you know even
in your 40s um
is that
craft really matters it really does
matter just being you know as a friend
of mine says just because you know how
to run the software it doesn't mean
you're an editor you know and just
because you can cut something doesn't
mean you know how to tell a story
um so forty to one
is about where i hover to answer your
question more succinctly why is it that
you emphasize that craft matters see it
seems obvious but it sounds like what's
underneath that is
that
you believe or that there is this trend
of that craft doesn't matter now when i
was speaking with jonathan blow he's a
video game designer he was saying hey
kurt right now there's this
the ethos in the industry is that skill
matters less and less he's citing
contemporary art when he says that if
you go to an art gallery contemporary
art
it's more about the statement that the
artist is making rather than the craft
behind it if you look at a renaissance
painting it just makes you
well
you're in tears looking at how much
artistry went into it so is that behind
what you're saying when you say look
craft matters or is it something else
i think
that it's a shame
if the bar is lowered
i think
that
while it may seem to have a place
delivering pablum to the masses
is a shame and a sin
i think elevating people enabling them
to elevate themselves
through
having the kind of craft that enables
you to elevate your own storytelling
your own art
then in process elevates them you just
gave me the perfect example of looking
at
you know
a renoir
you know uh or picasso
a serious craft there
today
you know
i'll give you the alternative example we
heard the story recently about the whole
um
fans only thing uh and how um you know
it's like a semi-pornish kind of site
and how uh that people were making lots
of money and this woman who was once a
nurse was
well in the article she called herself a
content creator technically speaking
she's
correct i suppose
but do not
conflate
content creator and producer
and artist anymore and that's what's
happening is we're conflating artists
with content creators
by having a woman who made who's making
250 000 a month doing what
pictures of her tna
that's content creation now
i've been doing this for 30 years and
i'm up against
a woman
showing pictures of her tna
and then in an article stating stating
i'm a content creator and i have a right
to blah blah blah
no
so i don't want to so i it's coming from
i don't want to see the bar tick tock
and youtube clips and instagram stuff
the bar comes down
hey i'm not against entertainment you
know i'm really not against a chuckle
and a laugh and i'm not against lowbrow
entertainment even that's fine but don't
and what what is it
don't don't piss on my back and tell me
it's raining mm-hmm
you know it is you're not a content
creator
um
so i'm actually gonna have to i'm gonna
have to relinquish that term because i
i'm losing that battle so fine you're a
content creator but you're not an artist
you're not a film producer you're not a
storyteller you're not even really a
creator capital c
don't don't don't do a tick tock video
of you punching your brother in the nuts
and call it art
you know so i'm
i'm not against that but i am kind of up
against it because i'm still putting
stuff out you know
i want to ask you a specific filmmaking
question yeah yeah please that's that's
that's why i'm here they're great in one
of your survivorman series
at times
you would cut in you would put the black
bars now it's already a low resolution
show in the sense that it's 480p in 2004
2005 and so on and i'm wondering and i
have a specific clip here just as a
filmmaker i'm
interested why did you choose
to put yeah i have it here can i just
link it to you so that you can you show
it to me yeah
okay i'm getting an ad of course
that's it it's your own doing you're
making a couple of sense right there ah
that's funny hang on let me turn that
off let me turn that off let me go there
no actually you're highlighting a um a
glitch in the uploading to youtube
that's all that is that was supposed to
be fixed that's nothing more than a
glitch it was supposed to be fixed you
see even after all these years and 30
years of filmmaking and everything else
stuff gets done and then you come back
and look and you go what why is that
there and you go and then you call you
hey
luke why is it oh that's a glitch sorry
man okay can you re-upload it please
that's just something that needs to be
fixed
there's this artistic choice there's a
reason because i've seen it more than
once
i know and it has
how the heck is that a glitch i do well
still to this okay recently i was
working with um team rubicon and
cleaning up at hurricane ida and i was
with the four filmmakers there the media
team and it was a lot of fun because
they were all young and they they did
listen to things i had to say which was
fun for me but right in the end there
the guy delivered the final cut we were
working on for that week
and he said oh i'll shoot it over to you
last now i could have said fine i'll
watch it when i get back to the hotel
right
but i was sitting right there i said oh
i'm gonna put it on now i watched it
absolute total big faux pas audio glitch
he completely missed and it would have
gone edited gone up to youtube right and
i said john is that supposed to be like
that and he goes what do you mean he
looks and goes
oh [ __ ] then he's like because he'd
already uploaded it to youtube so you
know hey yeah we all make mistakes as
well as the short answer there but um
but that i'll tell you another story on
that you know we'll go back to this
whole thing about content creators and
artists and so on so i am i also was
working with an individual
and we had a lot of broadcast delivery
to do and he'd never done broadcast
delivery before okay and it was a year
of conflict because
he had
been used to only uploading to online
under his own control no broadcast
delivery well you've got to understand
when you go pro
you know there is a difference
between uploading to vimeo
and and sending your work to discovery
channel
and filmmakers need to understand that
just because you could be a youtube star
when you go to deliver to
a e or discovery channel national
geographic you better bloody well have
every frame in the right spot every
color every audio it's very specific and
very detailed and very tedious
uh and a lot of hard work and i think a
lot of filmmakers don't understand
how
intense delivery to a broadcast network
like my deliveries right now to pbs uh
stations uh american public television
for the wild harvest series
you know that's all there's there's a
whole the specs there's three sheets of
specs
and you have to be bang on every single
one of those specs
because they're giving you money
and
it's important
no i was gonna say this is this is vital
personally i find it annoying because
there's no creativity there what i've
done because i have a documentary that i
gave to itunes
i used a distributor and then they take
care of that and then they send me back
these pages of notes why is it that in
this frame there's a small
black line over here
why is it that the audio does so and so
it peaks over here well peaking is a
simple issue to fix so i find it
annoying is there artistry in that in
meeting the
the distributor's requirements no
there's
no well there's
two ways to answer
if the glitches are real glitches you
want them to be known you want to solve
shame on you they've got to be fish i've
never
in all my years with discovery channel i
never delivered a show with glitches
uh because we no way we would not um
this recent round of deliveries there
was a whole bunch and that's what i was
saying i was working with an individual
who wasn't familiar because with you
vimeo or youtube ah
right it's like that and just put it
just uploaded it's fine
it's not fine when somebody on quality
control on the other end is looking
um
this is different from
notes on your content those are that's a
whole different level of interaction
with the networks when they're picking
apart your work
and they're giving you creative notes
and for people who can't see this i'm
doing air quotes around creative
uh so yes i mean i don't think the tech
specs hurt the artistry at all though
that's
you know deliver it deliver it right
it's going to a network which i think
people should follow so this stuff i
just did with team rubicon we're
uploading that to uh only to social
media but i went in and i and i and i
remember saying hey john you know the
handle on this little shot you should
the handle's a bit long
you see me getting ready to talk you
don't see me talking and she'll say oh
yeah
took it out go now doesn't that smoother
yeah it's way smoother right so
there is a craft in there you know
you know crap my editor will will my
very fair will often say like
you know
if you see that an editor has done a cut
on a blink
so that so the person on camera has
blinked
that's a self-taught cutter that's not
in it that's someone who does not know
the craft you know what are some of the
techniques you used to make your
footage or your episode more engaging
when there was a lack of
let's say engaging activities on screen
well engaging is an interesting word
story story story you know you hear that
content is king story will always be
king so that's mainly done during the
editing no no this no no this is this is
me filming in the field you know i have
see you know good in good out bad in
that out if i deliver my editor crap
he's got nothing it doesn't matter how
good of an editor he is now not enough
shows think that one through because
they take crap from their field and they
just edit it any old way they want you
know um my guy had to had to edit really
intense stories but i had to bring him
intense stories
so
you know one of my ways
was to
make sure i brought him a very strong
story so so that's now now
but to answer your question i'm in the
field so let's go there i'm in the field
and i'm lacking in content let's say
i'm lacking
i have to really there's two things i
did one is i have to either rack my
brain to think what can i pull out of
this area this next thing what have i
got here where's my story here and
sometimes i would just start filming
stuff
because you never know
the other side of it is
i would go in
i'm going to go in the desert today
let's say and i would have a a
list of things that i know i want to
capture for this particular story i'm
going to tell well it's the desert i
should tell a story about eating
strawberry pincushion uh cactus fruits
okay but the problem is in my situation
if it's day three and i haven't been
eating i forget so i pull out a crumpled
old piece of paper out of my pocket oh
yeah
pincushion fruit oh yeah okay i gotta
film that i'll go and now i go and i
film it so i keep myself on track with a
short list of don't forget to film this
kind of list
and i also you know and then maybe i
just have a good eye for looking around
going okay well there's a little bit of
story just in this next moment right
here let's capture this now what's the
difference between a story and just
filming an event so for example that
strawberry pin cushion
if it's written on a paper as a bullet
point you say film myself eating
strawberry and finding strawberry
pincushion
okay is that the story or do you somehow
add some elements around that to make it
a story
how do you take an event make it a story
essentially
i think what i do
is i say
oh well what's the story first of all
it's
this guy the guy happens to be me
and he's going to do this thing
okay the big one for me would be how
how is he going to do this thing what
are the hows that i can answer the first
towel is how do you find these bloody
things
okay
second how is all right how do you how
do you harvest these things do you know
okay now
there's two ways to harvest it
which one looks the best for camera
because you want things to look great on
camera i could just bend over and pick
up a pin cushion chariot
right or
i could get down on all fours
i could talk about avoiding rattlesnakes
i could talk about avoiding the spines
of the cactus i could show a tricky
little method for being able to use a
pair of tongs to pull off the the the
fruit rather than getting your fingers
stuck all of both situations i'm just
picking a cherry off of a bush
i'm just i forget that it's a cactus but
you know both situations i'm doing one
thing i'm picking something but one
situation i bend over and pick the other
one i've just given you three
pieces of information over how to do it
that's uh that's how i get the story in
something what's the how how is this all
going going down what are the nuances
that nobody at home would ever guess on
their of their own accord
you know what do i need them to know
fill them in fill them in tell them it's
all interesting
and what is interesting you can pull
from the edit you know
but fill it fill them fill in the story
some people will be wondering well what
the heck does this have to do with
theories of everything now as you know
theories of everything have to do with
physics it's gravity and then there's
the standard model how do you unify them
but it's also what what are the
fundamental laws that govern us so
consciousness may have a role to play
and if someone was to ask you
what does
what you do have to do with the theory
of everything
how would you answer that
no look here's one way theory of
everything has the word everything so no
matter what if i'm drinking tea it's
technically theory of everything
but is there some other way so the way
that i position theories of everything
theories of everything is an
investigation into theoretical physics
free will consciousness and god
because i see those as intimately tied
okay using that as your jumping off
point if someone was to ask you how the
heck does what you do maybe maybe it's
your mission maybe it's your shows how
does it relate
most of the time
i jokingly say i walk around in a mild
form of constant existential crisis
it's almost a
slight
addictive habit of mine
and yet
i've learned to befriend it over the
years it doesn't stop me
it doesn't
spiral me into depression or anxiety
because if you're constantly going
what's this all about
why how
you can really get bogged down in the in
in the muck and the mire of that
i use it
to
in many ways
calm me down
because
we have this tug of war this battle for
our consciousness
of
i need
to
matter i need to be relevant i need to
create i need to be part of this big
picture and what's going to happen when
i die and am i really a piece of energy
floating through space is this just
simply a biological thing that my spirit
and my energy have occupied at this
moment we have all of that versus
i'd really like that piece of cheesecake
and
i've been in between those for so long
in my life when i'm really frustrated it
bothers me to be in between because
why am i so dumb that i just really want
this piece of cheesecake and yet over
here i'm thinking about god
and so i've
been able to
let go of my existential crises when
they are detrimental to my own step
forward
and say look i am this physical being
all i really have
and that's even wrong there's gonna say
all i really have is this flesh in this
blood these muscles this brain but of
course
i'm happy to say that i'm quite certain
we could do so much more with the energy
of our minds
uh were we to be a little more advanced
and a little more skilled
that in the end
i try to bring it back to now here's
where it's going to sound almost woohooy
but
i still think in the end
that
expressing love
and not hating
express giving
and not just taking
all i know is that my concept of the
ethers and the great grand grand beyond
and god and spirit and energy and life
force
feels like it lands in a proper
place
if i am not being selfish if i'm not all
about myself and and which i can be very
easily and
so
my work moving forward
i believe has to somehow
fall into that same place
that my reasoning is falling into
which is yeah yeah of course there is
something greater here of course there
is a an energy
that is part of all things
and it's whether people name it or
orthodox it or box it up or not it's not
the point that
it's as far as i'm concerned
there's that yes there is the biological
sludge that came from the swamps of so
so sure
i will not
i i do not feel
that i'm just biological because if that
was true i wouldn't give a crap about
anything
so it it it
it brackets what i do because it causes
me to say okay if i'm going to create
something it's got to mean something
it's got to give it's got to be from
love if you will
um have i ever done things just for
money on occasion i have sure because i
needed money but
i'm not in that place anymore so now so
it's yes how does it govern
it governs by reminding me how big
everything is
but my touch this goes back to our first
convert part of the conversation but my
but by touchstone
with everybody watching
is that i still want to have that piece
of cheesecake
regardless of this bigger thinking no
matter how big our thoughts are
i still want to go home
and be with my wife and have a glass of
wine no matter how existentially i i
meandered you know why do you see that
as being against what you just said
because to me let's say the example of
wine with your wife that's an expression
of love you're sharing a moment
cheesecake alone
facing a wall scarfing it down that's
that's different and
you know just so you know it's not as if
it's clear that that's
different because some lines of thinking
is that
this universe is fractal-like and that
these patterns repeat so if you were to
investigate any phenomenon to its utmost
degree you still end up with a
reflection of the entire universe and
that's why some people say you can study
mathematics you can study logic if you
do it properly or do it to its extreme
you can find god if you study even these
headphones to its extreme because it's a
creation of god in a sense it's a
reflection of god then you can find god
but then i would ask you then can can
math explain
then i'm sure it can actually but then
where does the math rest when you look
at something like say having a piece a
cheap piece of cheesecake while staring
at the corner of a wall that you know
that
in the end it is not a positive maneuver
it is a
a negative element
it is a it is it is
an
energy that is not
even instinctually in keeping with
everything that's rolling on it in fact
it's a it's a pullback to the proper
outflow of love
man
have you heard of non-dualism
uh i've heard of it i couldn't explain
it to you but okay so the non-dualist
would say what i have to do is i have to
i have to go listen to more some more
sam harris and then i'll get back to you
all right so not duelist would say i
don't think sam
i don't think sam likes non-dualism
because he has he believes in morality
objective morality so the non-dualist
would say i'm not saying i'm a
nondualist i'm just being a mouthpiece
that there is no two non-dualist right
there is no two there is no up down
there's no evil there's no good that
it's all the same that in
it's like the atoms of the universe are
love because god is love the atoms of
the universe are love so that even in a
heinous act like what hitler did there
was love in that i'm not saying i
believe this but certain lines of
thinking would say that
well i watch too many marvel movies uh
to to think that everything i i don't i
don't think i agree with that i i i
think that um
what do i know right but i think that
hate is hate pain is pain anger is anger
intent to harm his intent to harm
um and uh
you know i i don't
see i mean i know i don't see where you
can derive the love out of those things
i i think they are the lack of love you
know in many ways and they certainly
exist
we don't there's no
question about the examples of how they
exist but you asked me about how this
this um
questioning of everything you know an
understanding of everything how it it
monitors my world
so what you're really asking me in many
ways is what do i believe you know and i
don't think it's a belief by the way i
think it's more what have i studied or
what do i feel
uh i've learned enough about to have at
least an opinion on
in my own life
i was a seeker when i was younger
i do not hold
with
orthodoxy or or church
orthodox
uh a go step further and i feel that
there is a place for it but i believe
what that is is the
kindergarten of spiritual seeking i
think it's the a good place for people
to go
if they need rules and regulations and
if they need rituals and traditions and
if they need colorful trinket trinkets
and colorful light things then then just
like kindergarten that's a good place to
go to start
start there you know
but i like being a seeker
i like being open and searching
and in my process now as a 60 year old
still feeling like i you know i could
listen to one podcast from from a great
thinker and go god i'm an idiot
but i don't really think i'm an idiot i
i
i have
felt enough
that whatever the answer here's the
thing you and i can't nobody's going to
answer this till they die none of us
know until our until till our breaths
leave this body none of us really know
even though regardless of altered states
even with an altered state
still can be certain but not quite that
certain
and then when we die we say oh
oh it is it's like this
um and there's plenty of stand-up comedy
routines to have fun with that
i've seen enough to basically say that i
do allow it to guide my life
i i don't need to be in a selfish state
anymore if i have over times
so that's that's
how questioning everything
i won't stop i won't stop questioning
everything trying to seek the
understanding of everything
i think we all i wish we all would
what do you see as the connection
between consciousness and bigfoot
that's a big question
the bigfoot phenomenon is a rabbit hole
so rabbit hole covered in ice with
greaseport over top of it
it's really slippery
and once you go down that rabbit hole it
leads off to a hundred other rabbit
holes
so
the question you ask is interesting
because
the journey of someone who wants who's
interested in that phenomenon starts off
looking for a big hairy ape
that's really smart
if you dig deep enough you leave that
school pretty quickly
it's no longer gigantopithecus the big
hairy ape that's really smart
and instead you start going wait a
minute
and then you keep having a whole bunch
of weight on minutes with attributes
various attributes
including potential
uh
telepathy um
and uh
cloaking and
all sorts of you know
various
versions of manipulating energy as well
so i think
consciousness and bigfoot
where it lands first of all nobody has a
freaking clue what these are
but the phenomenon is big enough
hundreds of years to thousands of years
hundreds of cultures all saying the same
thing by the way and tens of thousands
of anecdotal references
including sightings
some things there my question is
never mind just bigfoot
if that species is out there and i can
come back to them what else is out there
i mean you can't just go okay so this
bigfoot i'm going home now say well if
there's bigfoot
what else
and a lot of possibilities
open up
for example i think that
the potentiality is there for this
species nicknamed bigfoot but for
example sasquatch and whatever the
different names are to be a culmination
of all of these attributes people talk
about
which would include
uh
psychic abilities the ability of
telepathy
which would include cloaking abilities
which now one gentleman had a theory
that i still think hold some weight is
what if it was simply a species of
intensely savant autistic
individuals and their savant autism
gave them such extraordinary ability of
hide and seek
and on top of that a savant ability of
telepathy and survivability and they had
they understood how to manipulate their
own energy their own life force energy
to me all of that's possible if we're
talking about the potentiality of the
human mind but the minute you throw a
bigfoot into it oh that's just nonsense
exactly
how do you know it's not a species
that's way ahead of us okay they don't
compose symphonies they don't build
airplanes and cars i get that
that doesn't mean they can't do all
these other things so i didn't really
answer your question because i don't
know the answer to the to the comparison
of consciousness and bigfoot what i'm
suggesting is they
if they exist they are
in a realm of existence that we are far
from
grasping or understanding
and they're farther ahead than we are on
certain levels just way behind us in
other levels
why i'm asking is less you don't
disparage the bigfoot topic i don't
disparage the ufo topic even though
plenty of the scientific community would
and
i i'm pretty sure i was inspired by you
but either way
so if
sorry for stealing that from you
stealing your that's okay
okay either way when i was listening to
i believe it was some of your podcasts
or your commentary on some of the
bigfoot episodes before which have my
bone to pick with you man
which i'm going to put as an aside right
now i'm going to tell you that as i fall
asleep
i used to listen to your shows
and
and then
right and i have insomnia and right when
i'm about to fall asleep you play the
harmonica and i'm just cursing you and
i'm just wishing man i wish someone
would timestamp when those harmonicas
are so that i could start it from right
after either way bracket that i was
listening to and i believe you said
something like okay i went out to the
woods filming for bigfoot i think this
is way after the series you're filming
for bigfoot didn't occur so you thought
you know
there are stories that they can hear
what's going on with the cameras or
sense it in some manner so why don't i
turn the cameras off perhaps even do
some meditation exercise which is why i
brought up consciousness it's a
meditative exercise
and then you saw orbs and then i think
when i was listening to you said i can't
talk about it yet because you had just
gone through that experience and you
were processing it now am i correct
and if i am correct can you just
reiterate to the audience correctly what
i just perhaps incorrectly stated
no that was all correct that was from
the portland episode it was the last
thing i ever filmed uh it was outside of
the full series but it's on youtube now
yeah
what occurred can you talk about it now
well yeah i don't mind really it's it's
not that difficult to be honest with you
but the full story it's really it's the
story of of um
the potentiality of mental telepathy and
this particular species you see
when i was in tennessee in the episode
in tennessee if you want to go back and
watch that episode for example
uh and i've told this story uh i told it
just recently on
uh sasquatch odyssey a podcast
bottom line was that i was walking on
the trail on the way out and um never
ever
before in my life have i ever
experienced any kind of psychic or
telepathic phenomenon of any sort
whatsoever um and i wasn't high and i
wasn't drunk and i wasn't tired
and i'm walking i'm walking out and i
just had this
powerful voice
speak to me inside my head
and um
[Music]
so much so that after the fact i
actually went in to see a counselor to
make sure i wasn't schizophrenic because
it hit me that hard i thought i got to
know what's going on here
you know and the council reassured me
that no
you're far from schizophrenic don't
worry about that what what you received
was a gift and you should just celebrate
that fact and be really aware of that
and then it happened another two times
and then for the portland one that
you're referencing what happened there
was
i'm not i don't think i said this in the
show but
um
first of all i put my energy my thought
energy out there telepathically to the
sasquatch in that area that i was told
were there by a woman who has a
telepathic communication with them she
says
so i i you know said you know i'm coming
to meet you i did this for about a week
ahead of time and i started to
uh uh at one point feel like i was
getting
an answer if you will in my brain okay
fine so now i
yeah so now i go up there
and i go out in the bush and i'm and i'm
the orb thing had happened
and uh later on i'm just
sleeping on the ground and i was
starting to doze off in that little
crackling fire going
and all of a sudden i felt
a very
warm and actually felt a bit soft and
furry so it could have been anything
but it basically
went over my ankle and flipped my ankle
enough that it woke me up and i jumped
up immediately and it felt like a nice
big warm hand flipping my ankle over and
i jumped up immediately i didn't see
anything
fast forward to the next morning we're
walking out we run into the lady again
and we're planning on anyway anyway we
see her
i did not tell her this
and she says
she called him guardian so she's she's
given commitment
i was speaking with guardian and he told
me that during the night he came over
and touched you
and what do you do with that
she just that was the next morning she
said that to me after it actually
happened and i hadn't told her
and
those things
have happened to me about four times in
my life
without uh
forcing it lots of times nothing happens
something to remember too sometimes you
tell these stories people think oh
shit's going on all the time but
most of the time nothing's ever
happening see these are occurrences that
have happened over a number of years
i've had four telepathic experiences
anyway so that's what happened though of
that particular show and i i don't think
i i at the time was ready to talk about
that on camera and i didn't mention it
because if i mention it people go he's
losing it
right and i'm sure that's
ridicule
not so much during ridicule no it's not
the ridicule i fear it's their inability
to handle the full story and yes i'm
belittling them when i say that yes i
sound a little condescending when i say
that but screw them if i just say hey
yeah pikmin talk to me
all the chuckles starts like okay you
know what but i could say that to a lot
of people that go really tell me what
happened
that's the person i like to share
with okay it's okay so let's say a week
prior to you going out and experiencing
that orb you were doing some exercises
where you were trying to contact bigfoot
via intention
and meditating something like that
more via psychic outreach like
specifically speaking so i've done it
several times
and and nothing's ever happened but a
couple of times i have gotten an answer
one time it was actually rather quite
funny
i would go on a hike so if people are
wondering how to do this i mean i would
go on a hike and i would just if i want
an interaction i would just put it out
there and just say you know i'm coming
out i'm going to be hiking
in an area you know don't know if
anybody's even there but if someone is
there i would be welcoming in love to
have some kind of interaction
and then often as i
and
nothing okay and i just go as you go
like
one time though
bam in the middle of my head all i got
was
no thanks for sleeping
i mean it's just the craziest thing and
again remember the first time this
happened i went in to see a counselor
and i've only had this happen four times
in my whole life okay
but i'll tell you it is the strangest
thing ever when it happens it's so
strong
anyone who who is who has this as a
skill in their life will just go yeah of
course that that they wouldn't even they
would accept this conversation with zero
judgment
now these four times it's occurred to
you were they each single sentences just
like no we're sleeping or were they so
the paragraph i'll give you the i'll
give you i'll give you the script sure
uh the the
the first time was
we're right over here
if you want to meet us stay the night
to which i replied this in tennessee to
which i replied
because the first time anything like
this ever happened in my life and i was
scared and the hair was up on the back
of my neck i had never felt that and i
said i'm not ready
and they said
that's fine
and they walked away
and i
okay
that was in my mom so that's cool when
they said we're here did they give you a
location or they said here and it was
implied they were near you
both the location was basically the hill
right over there that i could see from
about 150 feet away
that's pitch black i'm in the dark
uh-huh
and
the image in my brain that was seared in
my brain was of a large hulking male
figure and a small child
in both in classic bigfoot look okay if
you will
and that really freaked me out um and
nothing and then i think a couple of uh
well no actually a few months went by
after that one the next one was a little
more menacing
um it was during a meditative process on
the texas bigfoot episode and that one i
never told anybody on camera but there i
did get during the meditation stage i
got i got a uh yeah yeah get get get
ready get ready for this was kind of
sort of the message and it felt menacing
and dark and i didn't like it and i
didn't i just kind of no
no no not going here
the third time was the
uh in oregon and it was the answer in my
brain was simply
no thanks for sleeping and the fourth
time is the portland portland episode
where where basically this particular
being said
um
yeah yeah we're here we're ready for you
you know and uh and that was a wonderful
experience so am i crazy uh am i
are these are they hallucinations is it
lucid dreaming is it blah blah blah blah
blah blah i don't know but i know that
in all instances i was wide awake
very sober very straight and
not
trying to make this happen in my brain
and i've tried many many other times and
nothing happens
but these times they just see it sears
in the middle of your brain you can just
it's just you can't not hear it you know
when the first time you had a back and
forth or at least you said one statement
which is i don't think i'm ready
did you say that in your mind did you
say it out loud how did you say it yeah
i say it in my mind and so someone's
going away oh yeah sure they'd speak
english sure sure no what they do is
it's a process of your mind deciphers
for you what you're supposed to
understand and to me that if i was
chinese it would be it would be in
mandarin you know or something uh so
so uh
yeah yeah so so so yeah it's it says
that yeah so you gave your intention
like hey i'm not ready currently okay
now when they spoke to you
all of these times were they instantly
understood or were they understood
linearly like when you read you
understand the first word the next one
then the next one and the next one or
was it all at once they said that
sentence to you
interesting question
the the sentences were short enough that
the distinction would be too hard to
make
i'm not sure that i could decipher it
linearly or in a linear fashion or if it
was all at once it was just too short
okay and as an aside the reason is that
some people when they speak to other
beings or
let's say even they have an encounter
with god it's as if
all of that is said to them like that
and it's not like it's like when you
read one word you don't read each letter
you read the word instantly
if i if i was forced to make the
distinction that is what i would say i
would say it feels like it's all at once
it's just that the statuses were short
so it
same thing sort of thinking
is it all right if i ask you a couple of
details of the orbs of what the heck
happened there okay so firstly how large
were the orbs and what color were they
where did they come from when did they
come why
well you won't be able to answer why
well i mean i was we were uh devin and i
because devin was with me on that one we
were sitting and i just heard
devin go
hey les come here you've got to look at
this
and i and i something like that and i
get up and i walk over to devin he was
10 feet away 15 feet away
and about 15 feet away from him
were two
hovering
orbs
one the size of a golf ball one the size
of a pie plate the pie plate one was
much more fuzzy and less distinctive the
golf ball was more focused in if you
will
they stayed hovering there
and you could see like gentle hover
in their movement
but in the same position
for i want to say a good 15-20
minutes enough for us to look and go is
there car lights flashing off something
is there local i mean we're in the
middle of the forest right
our eyes are you know i mean we're all
clear again straight
you know no no uh
we weren't smoking anything or drinking
anything silver
and um
i think what's going on there
if this species truly exists this
phenomenon is actually something is that
one of its attributes is its ability to
manifest or ability to manipulate its
own life force energy and in doing so it
has a physical manifestation which is
the big hairy creature we see that
smells and shits and eats and screams
and throws rocks
and the other manifestation which
potentially could be in as light energy
which we would then translate as being
an orb
and and also the other message that we
got the next morning from the woman who
is an empath and a psychic with these
beings that she said
that
she was told that some of the others not
the one guy that supposedly flipped me
over at night but some of the others
came to look at us in the earlier part
of the night and that's when the orbs
were there
okay what color were the orbs both the
same color too
like you're sure whitish
have you heard of any connections
between ufos and bigfoot
of course i've had people i've heard
people say that often often often often
um my first craziest experience was on
the mountain in radium springs and there
was a scenario that happened there that
i do not believe i mentioned on the show
because i didn't want to confuse the
viewers it's the other thing right
sometimes you
you're forced
before you feed somebody filet mignon
you've got to get give them a taste of
meat first all right you know and so uh
that night um i looked over in the skies
and i saw these four big lights they
were massive huge
and they were all lined up and they
could not have been airplanes but they
were up in the sky and they were just
there
for 20 minutes
and then i went back and i'm not sure
where i went to go maybe i went to get
my camera
came back they just they were gone they
disappeared and i've never seen anything
like that in my entire life and i'm just
like oh my god like i'm thinking this is
but at the time i'm just like
oh this is cool what the hell is at the
time i'm like what the hell is that and
that was the night you were with devon
or that was a different night
no this is the night i'm alone this is
on the mountain top of mountain mountain
in radium springs but i was one of my
survival bigfoot episodes
that was the night after those lights
where i felt
i'd had something come in and sit on top
of me while i was trying to sleep and
everybody's going to say that's old lady
syndrome that sleep paralysis i get that
i'm familiar with that that is not what
i felt that night it felt
like somebody was sitting on me with
very large buttocks
and then that next morning the of these
apples had put on a tree they all
disappeared and the camera was filming
didn't catch anything they just
disappeared on camera the whole night
was freaked out but my point is that it
started with those big four lights in
the sky and you said you know connection
of ufos to bigfoot i don't know
i really don't know the thing about it's
the world of the phenomenon of
sasquatches
over on one side here it's a big hairy
ape that's smart and on this side it's
aliens and everything in between you
know
able to travel dimensions that's what
you mean by the slippery rabbit hole
with mud and so on
yes although more so what i need but
what i mean by the rabbit hole is is my
line of whoa if there is sasquatch what
else is there
have you heard of skinwalker ranch
of course yes yeah okay so see when i
was researching a bit about ufos then i
read about skinwalker ranch and the fact
that there
have been observed portals whether or
not this is true there's been observed
portals perceived portals and then
sasquatch coming out and then this is a
place where there's plenty of ufo
activity and poltergeist activity as
well it's a strange confluence of all
these unexplained phenomenon
and you know when
as a scientist when you hear about let's
say well what's consciousness have to do
with
someone saw a phenomenon the scientists
would always say there's this tendency
in us to say unexplained phenomenon here
unexplained phenomena well they're
related somehow because they're both
unexplained and that's a foolish mistake
but when it comes to
bigfoot and ufos
well let's just say bigfoot and ufos it
seems as if it's more than just the
connection being drawn because there's
question marks over each
in other words okay well you want to
riff on that yeah well i nominate i just
think that um
i
i just think existence is so much bigger
than our human
little human brains can can
can comprehend and and the thing is it
doesn't scare me
the rabbit hole doesn't scare me
it's just like yeah of course i mean
we've had so much about ufos that if a
ufo landed in new york tomorrow
everybody would go oh yeah i figured
they were there
we get a lot of that you know like oh it
becomes the de facto of course the uh
aliens exist i knew that
who didn't know i knew but we don't
really know
um
i just think
my mind has always been
is this possible
and the answer to every single
question that that's asked on in my mind
is could be yep
i'm wide open to it and here's the thing
that doesn't scare me and the problem is
that it scares a lot of people
and and certainly a lot of religious
people it really scares them because
then you're going to bring satan into it
right so to me
none of it
i just don't feel a fear and i'm not
being machismo i just think
the possibilities are endless and isn't
that awesome
have you felt the fear and then you
managed to overcome it or just
temperamentally you don't feel the fear
when it comes to that
temperamentally i don't feel the fear
uh and also i'm well aware of the fact
that
if i was face to face with an alien
tomorrow
uh
he's got a he or she or it has a huge
advantage over me of course yeah right
so what am i going to do about it you
know what can i actually do go grab my
ak-47
actually i wouldn't say of course sorry
i would step back and the reason i say
that is that there's some view that
certain aliens
have
let's say evil intent or negative intent
and that they cannot read our minds
although you can communicate with them
by intending like you did with the
bigfoot but they can't read your mind
and it's and the human capacity for love
is what extinguishes
well it extinguishes hate and so in some
sense let's say there are multiple types
of aliens and one is evil then you do
have a power over the evil ones with
your love so that's why i say well i
don't say of course oh i think i think
i think that's wonderful fanciful
thinking but if that were true then
nobody'd ever be heard would it because
there's a lot of loving caring people
that have been murdered
why didn't they why didn't their
capacity for love just stop the human
being from murdering them
i i i no no i i think
you know i hear i hear about the grays
for example i hear about the grays and
uh i'm not look when i had my first
experience what did i say to you the
hair was up on the back of my neck and i
felt very very nervous and i was too
afraid to stay
i said i'm not ready for this
do i kick myself
yeah a little but i wasn't ready so
there was fear there i'm saying as a
general rule i don't walk around guiding
my life based on fear of the unknown i
love that the unknown and embrace the
unknown it's just that there will be
aspects of the unknown that could be
very detrimental to me and could harm me
and i don't think my capacity to love is
going to stop me if i'm by myself in the
middle of a the forest and there
actually are grays and a gray comes over
to a cost me you know i've heard that
that sasquatch are there and often
protect humans from the graves i've
heard that's a storyline people say i
mean so you know i'm just kind of like
you know when it's my time it's my time
i don't want to feel pain i don't want
to hurt i don't want to be abducted i
don't want to anal probe but hey i'll
just go and
you know that's not going to stop me
from experiencing any of these things
okay let's get to some audience
questions crepetus s asks i've seen
almost everything that
you've done less and i've appreciated
your recent embrace of posting
everything on youtube frankly i've had
medical issues and i've watched les's
survival shows when i couldn't eat and i
was in pain and it was extremely
therapeutic
has less ever considered doing an urban
survival show
no i'll tell you why not as people ask
sometimes will you do like almost like a
homeless kind of thing right
my problem with that is every time i get
down to the brass tacks of doing it it
feels like i would actually kind of be
disrespecting people who are truly
hurting and truly homeless to go and do
a survival show where i'm digging what
digging in a dumpster
the other answer to that is
i don't give a crap about the city i'm a
nature nut i'm a wilderness guy my stuff
is all based on being in nature i'm not
there to teach you survival
i or do survival tricks like these other
shows i'm showing you survival
techniques to facilitate getting you out
in the wilderness so no i won't do an
urban show because of that
bookman asks about limits i want to know
about him pushing through personal
limits doing hard things is tough but
controlling the mind is tougher how has
survival shifted his mindset
the rewards are greater
to do
the heavy lifting
can break your back
but if it doesn't
then the rewards are so much greater
and
the survival component of what i've done
has been painful at times but hey
i'm sitting here right now
i just had a wonderful cappuccino some
cheesecake i'm on the other side of it
and some cheesecake you know so
i the beauty of
pushing through the difficulties
is then when you have you have the
perspective perspectives everything in
life travel is so important i just wish
people would do more of that
and pain and and
and
struggle
uh give you perspective if we bubble
wrap ourselves and protect ourselves we
just don't have any perspective
uh anymore and uh
so i just always knew that so that's
that's how i would that's how it changed
i i learned that getting to the other
side of pain getting the other side of
struggle and survival traveling and
seeing the world these things
give me perspective
and when i have that perspective and i'm
in conversation i don't get caught up in
[ __ ]
paul v wants to know when times are
hardest what is the one thing that gives
you the strength to carry on
trying to think of when times are
hardest
feeling like i'm not done
or reminding myself
that i'm not done i don't ever want to
finish
ever
i want to be
you know just putting out a novel on my
97th birthday just before i die or
something you know
just reminding myself that i'm not
finished and i have more yet to do
gets me going keeps me going it's like
okay all right suck it up let's get up
and go again you know
at stan allister asks have you ever used
any of wim hof's cold endurance
techniques if so can these extend one
survival in harsh conditions
uh
i if if the harsh condition is being
submersed in ice cold water sure
because that's what it is uh yeah
that'll extend that you jump out of a
boat in alaska i mean that's probably
going to help that absolutely i think
but then overall sure i mean i do
believe and agree with the with the
concept of it um simply because i felt
my own body felt stronger and felt
better because of doing the wim hof
methods so yeah i i like i said
notwithstanding earlier conversation
about potential tinnitus from the
breathing um yeah i think whims on to
something pretty great uh and and i do
adhere i haven't gotten into his
meditative techniques yet but the first
i've got steps one and step two
definitely
james mckevitt asks kurt in canada most
outdoorsmen have watched survivorman
religiously by the way i'm from toronto
in case he didn't know less
did mr stroud ever suffer any long-term
physical or mental duress from his
extreme survival outings thank you
no not at all zero um two reasons for
that i've had short term i've had
parasites that's the only thing that
that's really been an issue but i've
taken care of those with some pills
basically um and otherwise no uh no long
term
uh
no no
it's funny because
it's the opposite
i think i'm out in nature
seven days alone it's it nature heals
nature strengthens nature nature
de-stresses
and i get that healing that
strengthening and that distressing
uh
to the nth degree
so
no i i have no long term and no short
term really i have nothing but benefit
benefits
jimmy lee says
okay i'm interested in what kind of
theory of everything does survivor man
has how does he feel about the great
reset
and the technocratic neo-feudalism which
we seem to be headed for so how does he
feel about the great reset
firstly what the what is the great reset
and then how do you feel about it
i'm assuming he's talking when he says
the great reset i assume i'm assuming
he's talking about right now this moment
in time with the pandemic because that's
what everybody's calling the great reset
um and and
uh
how do i feel about it what an
interesting way to ask that how do i
more about the technocratic
neo-feudalism we seem to be headed for
just this morning
i was thinking that here's how i feel
about it
that i want to turn my back on it and
continue creating
because
getting caught up in all of that going
on around us is not good for the soul
uh
if it's your thing
okay
but i gotta be honest
it's never been my thing to get caught
up in these big moments in time like
this in fact when i was an outdoor guide
stuff used to come and go in the world
and i barely even knew i'm not saying be
selfish live selfishly but what i'm
saying is i better serve
this
greater theory of everything if you will
if i am
putting
content out that uplifts people inspires
people brings about a positive influence
on people's lives i better i'm better
served and i better serve this great
thing that's that's going on we call
life if i concentrate on that and i and
i'm not copying out from the question
i'm saying it's i
i turn back i turn my back on it
on that question because i i just
it'd be a waste of my energy to try to
be to try to even have a feeling about
it right now you know
some guy oh that's not a cop-out no no
no not at all it's a great perspective
some guy asks
have you found that being
have you found that being comfortable
alone is one of the most important
skills to have today
well first of all being comfortable
alone is an important skill but the most
important one of the most important
skills to have today being comfortable
alone
i'm going to say you know i'll say
yes that has merit
for one if it's forced upon you then you
you have that you have that skill set
you have that
that
that uh associated muscle memory with
being alone if you're comfortable with
it you're okay all right well i'm going
to be alone for a bit okay i can deal
with that and some people can't they
panic
um
but is it one of the more necessary
skills and more vital skills
uh
it's circumstantial i think that's a
circumstantial skill
and if your circumstances
indicate that that may be part of your
future then sure you better be
comfortable with being alone but if if
not
then you can you can cruise you can
cruise without really developing that
skill set and concentrate on other
skills skill sets where you're more
gregarious and you're more you're more
you're more involved with people and so
on so i i say it's circumstantial but
yeah if your circumstances push for it
then yes it's an important skill
okay two more questions philip warham
asks he may have spoken about this
already but ask him about prepping
especially for climate change and emp
slash solar storms
yeah um
so i'm sorry to burst the bubble here
but
i think prepping
if you see prepping as
building a bunker in the backyard
having a set of shotguns and various
guns having your store and being ready
to to protect your land as the way to
prep because that's what i originally
saw as preppers
preppers now will say no that's not us
we're just we're just having good
supplies on it so all right well then we
have to define preppers in my brain
preppers is the guy building the bunker
okay so let's just go with that i'm not
talking about people who are getting
themselves prepared
see that's how i interact because i
don't know about this word prepper
yeah so no preparation so
being prepared
of course it's a that's a no-brainer
but the other version i think i think
they're very very foolish individuals
first of all whatever goes down
we're not going to be ready for it
you know you oh i'm going to go out i'm
just going to hunt deer and fish for
for walleye and i'll be set yeah and if
the lakes are full of acidification and
the deer have died because of you know
radiation what really
no you're not um i'm going to sit here
in my bunker and protect myself really
so if your
12 year old daughter comes to you and
tears and and says can my best friend
and their family come and live with us
because their house was was ruined in
the disaster you're going to sit there
with a shotgun and go no stay away no
you're going to let them in so
i think a lot of the hardcore prepper
stuff is just [ __ ] and silly and
nonsense and small-minded
[Music]
and also by the way everybody else who
has a bunch of guns also knows who has
all the food
and we know you have all the food
so and we have bigger guns you know what
i'm saying it's just it's a silly
situation
but um
i think better than being prepared with
food on hand i think better than being
prepared with spare clothing and
equipment and this
is being prepared with skill sets
that enable you
to survive through whatever
if you were just there in your clothes
how to be adaptive how to how to find
things how to you know scrounge things
that to me is stronger and then
secondarily yes
i have a lot of food in my basement yes
have you thought about making a course
like you hear many youtubers do
skillshare have you thought about making
course whether it's on skillshare or
whatever it may be
on how to survive or is it so different
in each environment
oh it's vastly different in each
environment and i i kind of have right
because if you think about it 20 years
of creating survival films with
survivorman and the like those those
films read out like a course i wasn't
making a tv show i was teaching you how
to survive and i just launched the
series surviving disasters with less
drought on pbs stations in the united
states and on um
and on youtube here in canada and those
are meant to teach you ways to survive
natural disasters so
yeah i could do the whole online course
thing
but you know the thing about that is uh
kurt is is that
to me
that's max of being a businessman
doing something for a business sense
i've been doing courses my whole career
and putting them out there in film form
uh so i i'm not into
business
all right last question comes from
dwayne elizondo mountain dew herbert
camacho that's all one name
he wants to know regarding the missing
apple slash candy on his bigfoot special
and bigfoot in general does he think
there could be a species that is both
interdimensional and low-tech that is
primitive even
yeah absolutely i do and that's what i
mean by their ability to manifest their
own it to to manipulate their own life
force energy and then manifest and then
the amount of different manifestations
so there's a physical manifestation or
manifestation who knows if we could do
it i'd do it you know what if i could
men if i could manipulate my own life
energy
perhaps i could vibrate to a point where
i'm not visible to the eye anymore
right and be cool as hell sub question
from him like have you ever experienced
lost time while camping
do you understand what he means by that
oh i totally do and you know the short
answer is no i haven't i know what he
means but i have not
les what do you have to promote where
can people find out more about you
what's next for you
okay actually i'll do an addendum that
question i did experience last time
while in the middle of a car accident so
there you go
and heard a very strong voice that told
me to move and if i didn't move i was
going to break my neck so i moved and i
did not break my neck but i did break
three ribs punctured along and dislocate
two shoulders
how old are you that was
uh this is just a couple years ago and
it happened in slow motion i mean it was
legitimate slow motion in that role it
was unbelievable
um
my wife was beside me she experienced
the exact same thing slow motion it
watched it happen no voice happened very
fast but no voice for her though
no
so uh the biggest thing for me really is
my youtube i'm i'm really having fun
putting everything else everything on
youtube survivorman lestrade um i have a
brand new book out for kids wild outside
getting your kids out in nature again
uh and it's for them by the way written
to them
um i have a brand new um i'm finally
releasing my mother earth album on
double vinyl fold out double fold out
final album this year and two new albums
after that
and uh and then i have my uh two series
that are on the pbs stations presented
by american public television that is
wild harvest local foraging turning them
into an amazing meal and surviving
disasters with less drought about
surviving natural disasters so a lot on
the go all the time a lot of this stuff
outflowing um
and uh
getting all the way back to what you
originally asked and i think the reason
is because i really don't want
to cease
this manifestation
of my life force right now i like the
flesh and blood manifestation of my life
force and that flesh and blood
emotionally
wants to be a prolific artist and that's
where that's the world now because you
are
and continue to be
continue to be abs absolutely and that's
what keeps me putting so it's a lot i
love having a long list of things to say
thank you man it was an honor for me to
be able to speak with you
thank you very much love the questions
uh and and love this podcast so i
appreciate it thanks man
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t
j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l that is kurt jaimungle
it's support from the patrons and from
the sponsors that allow me to do this
full-time every dollar helps
tremendously thank you